Jamie Authorities say,
this is now a criminal investigation.
Several fires raging now down this street,
smashing grab flash mob at a Nordstrom
police, the number of homeless people on the streets
and in shelter, medical treatment for minors,
a surprise attack within Israel's borders.
People are for
holding fireworks.
And an angel of the Lord appeared to them
and the glory of the Lord shown around them
and they were filled with fear.
And the angel said to them, fear not for behold.
I bring good news of great joy.
Well, Merry Christmas Church.
Uh, if you are new here, we're grateful
that you would gather with us.
Uh, we're always honored by that.
And so please get to know us.
We hope you're welcomed and encouraged while
you're here with us today.
Uh, my name's John, one of the pastors here.
And so just invite you now to turn in your copy
of God's word to Luke chapter two.
Luke chapter two. We're gonna see one
of the more forgotten characters in the Christmas story.
His name is Simeon Luke two is where we'll be today.
We're continuing our series, looking into this good news
of great joy that Christ's arrival brought.
And we're looking at what a few characters said
and their perspective on this nativity scene
as we get into it today.
I want to tell you about what happened on July 4th, 2004.
And so I had invited my girlfriend over
to my house in Stillwater, where we were gonna hang out
for the afternoon before heading out to Boomer Lake
that night to watch the fireworks.
And little did she know
that I'd also invited our families over to a friend's house
where they were getting dinner ready together.
And I think you know where this is heading
at this point right now,
my heart was beating pretty heavily Iactually
feel right now, a little bit.
Um, all day. I was anxious.
That energy in your stomach kind
of gets a little stirring up in your soul, right?
And, and in reality, I was probably the most nervous
because I'd, I'd written her a song that I was going to sing
to her and, uh, play on my guitar.
Now, just, no, don't do that. Listen, it was terrible.
Like it was, oh man.
Uh, it was the only song I've ever written.
And I knew like four basic chords.
She kind of pluck through GCD kind of thing.
And uh, yeah, uh, it was, listen, the only reason I did it's
'cause that's what you're supposed to do back in 2004
with John Mayer, right?
Anybody know that? And that's just write the cool song.
It was not good.
So she graciously as I stumbled through that, uh, but,
but then very simply right there in my bedroom
at this nasty house I lived in, in college,
we were there in my bedroom.
I just went down simply in my knee
and proposed, uh, for her hand in marriage in that moment.
And so she said yes.
We went over to our friend's house to tell them
where her family and my family surprised her there.
And we ate dinner, went to Boomer Lake, fireworks, all that.
It was super sweet. But here's the point.
From July 4th, 2004
until May 14th, 2005, when we actually got married,
we were waiting, living
between two events, right?
Something had happened
and something was going to happen in the future.
And, and in between those two dates, we were waiting.
We were waiting between proposal and between the vows.
So she'd said yes,
but soon was coming that we were both going to say I do.
Right? There was a gap between those.
Yet I heard a pastor talk about this recently that that kind
of waiting between those two things is very unique, kind
of waiting that there are all kinds of seasons of waiting
that we have in our lives, like waiting
for test results where you hope something didn't happen
or hasn't happened or isn't happening,
or there's waiting on something that may never happen.
Like you may never get that call back from the job,
or you may never have that relationship you long for,
or there's a waiting that's frustrating.
Like when you're sitting at a red light
and you're like, this thing's been way too long,
or this morning when your kid just wasn't getting ready
quickly enough, you're waiting.
And it's frustrating.
But this in-between waiting is different.
It's a waiting that looks back at something
that has happened, yet it is also linked
to something that will happen.
So in between, there's this measure of, of confidence
that we have,
because the thing that I'm waiting for,
I already have a measure of it in my life.
See, our relationship changed on July 4th, 2004.
So between Emily and me, there was a, a stated public love
and commitment, but it wasn't the same way,
not the same way it would be at the wedding.
Yet think about that in between waiting like
that changed our lives, right?
That in-between process, something had happened, right?
So we began to prepare for something that was going
to happen, prepare for the wedding.
We began to prepare for our life together for the marriage.
We would have. We, so you're starting to look for houses,
you're starting to find jobs.
You're figuring out how this is all gonna work,
and bank account, all that stuff.
You're starting to figure that out.
Premarital counseling, you're doing these things to prepare
for a future event.
It was an active waiting, not just sitting
around doing nothing, waiting for a date in the future,
Something had happened and something would happen.
And that life was lived in between.
And Christian, listen, because of when you were born,
all of our lives are lived in the, in-between
2000 years ago, God, the son took on flesh,
born in Bethlehem, ministered in Galilee,
crucified in Jerusalem, resurrected in power,
ascended back to heaven in glory.
That happened then.
And one day in the future, he is going to return
to make all things right.
He's going to give us his presence face-to-face,
not just spiritually, where we'll see him in perfect peace
and perfect joy.
For now, though we're waiting, we're in between.
Yet it can be a confident waiting
because something has happened.
We know that something will happen.
And so we already have a measure of it already,
which gives us confidence that it's coming in the future.
Simeon shows us what faithful waiting looks like.
He's in a different season of waiting. We'll see that.
But he shows us as we look at Luke two.
Now this, this example of faithfulness
in the in-between that he was in.
So look now Luke two starting in verse 22.
And when the time came for their purification, according
to the law of Moses, they, that's being Joseph and Mary.
They brought him Jesus up to Jerusalem to present him
to the Lord as it is written, the law of the Lord.
Every male who first opens the womb shall be called
holy to the Lord.
And to offer a sacrifice according to
what is said in the law of the Lord, a pair of turtle doves
or two young pigeons.
Now, we've, we've actually jumped ahead
in the narrative a little bit here.
So we're not going in chronological order.
This is a scene that is after Jesus has already been born.
We're gonna take next week, Christmas Eve
to look at the actual birth narrative in Luke two earlier.
Uh, but, but today we've jumped ahead and,
and we're gonna look at, at how faithful these people were.
So first we see Jesus's parents, how devout they were
to following the Lord.
It describes some events that are kind of confusing to us.
We don't really know what this looks like in our day,
but the purification that this is talking about was mandated
by God's law for a mother after giving birth,
because that would ritually make her unclean.
And so they had a process to be cleansed in that sense.
So that's what they were coming to do.
But it was also a time for this new family
to worship the Lord, to give thanks to the Lord
through the sacrifices that they would offer.
By the way, notice that this, this was a poor family.
They couldn't even afford a lamb to offer a sacrifice.
So God gave a stipulation.
They could have two birds instead of a, a lamb and a bird.
That's how poor Jesus grew up.
So just know God uses all kinds of families in this.
But notice Joseph and Mary, they were so committed
to faithfully obeying the Lord.
What did they do? They, they sacrificed, they purified,
but they also then dedicated this miracle baby to the Lord.
Again, the Old Testament required that
of the firstborn people would do that ritual.
But Joseph and Mary actually followed through.
They said, this is important to us here.
This baby God gave us, God, it's yours.
So Joseph and Mary, great examples of faithfulness.
But, but next, we're introduced to Simeon,
and this is our main focus today.
And I want you to look at verses 25 and 26 to start with.
Now, there was a man in Jerusalem whose name was Simeon.
This man was righteous
and devout waiting for the consolation of Israel.
And the Holy Spirit was upon him,
and it had been revealed to him by the Holy Spirit
that he would not see death
before he had seen the Lord's Christ, the Messiah.
And so here we're introduced to this idea of waiting, right?
But, but what was Simeon waiting on?
It says he was waiting on the consolation of Israel.
It's an interesting phrase.
We don't talk like that very often. But what is consolation?
What does it mean to console someone?
Well, it means when someone is down, you work at trying
to encourage them, trying to cheer them up.
You, you work at ways to alleviate their grief.
Take the pain away. That's what consolation is.
And that happens all over the New Testament.
You see people like Anna, which is right
after the story of Simeon, we're not gonna study that fully,
but Anna is waiting for the redemption of Israel.
There's others waiting for the kingdom of God to come.
You see it all over the place.
But what they're waiting for is
what Isaiah 700 years earlier prophesied.
Isaiah 40, verses one
and two says, comfort, comfort, my people, says your God,
speak tenderly to Jerusalem
and cry to her that her warfare is ended,
that her iniquity is pardoned,
that she's received from the Lord's hand, double
for all her sins.
See, they were waiting on this comfort
that the warfare would be over.
Peace would come. The prince
of peace we now know would come.
Simeon was waiting in between God's promises he'd made like
that one and the Messiah's arrival,
waiting for the consolation of Israel, waiting
for this Christ, the Messiah, to come
and fulfill these promises, to renew their hope.
Isaiah said it again in Isaiah 25 verse
nine, about that day.
It says, it will be said on that day, behold,
this is our God.
We have waited for him that he might save us.
This is the Lord. We have waited for him.
Let us be glad and rejoice in his salvation.
Right? So Simeon is looking back at God's
promises, God's character.
And he's looking not only at the 700 years ago
and further promises, he's also then been told
by God's spirit that he was gonna get to see the Messiah.
So he's banking on all these promises.
And as he waited, he was saying, God, I know Yahweh,
I know you're gonna come through for your people.
I know you will come through for us. That's faith.
Now, that is the context into which
these three, four people entered into that temple
on that particular day with Joseph
and Mary carrying the weeks old savior of the world,
Simeon led by the Holy Spirit into the temple.
They didn't know each other, we assume before this moment.
Yet when Simeon saw that young family, when he saw
that baby, he immediately knew.
And so I just want you to imagine for a second just kind
of picture in your head, the temple Simeon, Joseph
and Mary holding baby Jesus.
Just kind of picture that moment in your head
and just imagine for a second, imagine
Simeon's demeanor as he walked over
to this young couple
that he saw maybe from afar in the temple courts.
And he, and he walks towards them
with his tear filled gaze just fixed on that child.
Now, now we might think Mary would be afraid of this
stranger walking towards her like this, right?
She'd be like, kinda carry in like Joseph, get in the way.
Um, but remember the, the spirit
of God was all over this scene, right?
This was God's work.
And and so Simeon, we know gently tenderly walks over
and picks up baby Jesus.
And as he holds Jesus in his arms,
he couldn't help but worship.
He couldn't help but bless God. Praise God.
It's what we have recorded here.
And Luke two, look at verses 29 through 32,
these beautiful truths that Simeon declares
as he's holding the Savior in his arms.
He said, Lord, now you are letting your servant depart in
peace according to your word,
for my eyes, have seen your salvation
that you've prepared in the presence of all peoples, a light
for revelation to the Gentiles, for glory
to your people Israel, meaning this is universal.
God, thank you for it.
But, but I want you to see what Simeon just said. Right?
No, notice what he just said.
Basically, he was saying, God, I, I don't have
to watch this child grow up.
Like I don't even need to see him do anything.
I don't need to hear him say anything.
I don't need to watch miracles walking on
water, see his resurrection.
I don't need any of that.
I've seen all I need to see, let me die in peace.
He didn't care about vindication
because he had been waiting.
He'd been living as if this was going to happen.
He didn't walk around saying, I told you.
So he just wanted to enter into this rest
and peace that God had promised for thousands of years.
He's like, I've got, I see it. He's here.
He didn't care what other people thought.
He focused on the Lord.
It's interesting, even the word he uses
for Lord here in the opening line
of this is not the typical word used in the New Testament.
It's actually where we get our word today, despot.
That's got a negative connotation in our day, right?
But it wasn't used that way in the New Testament, Simeon,
what he's doing with that is he's acknowledging
my total allegiance, my submission
to the absolute authority God has.
God, I am your servant.
Well, of course, Mary and Joseph,
as this stranger says these things, they were in awe.
Which by the way, all the things Mary and Joseph have heard
and seen by this point, why
would they still be amazed at this?
Right? But they were,
and I think more of it is not surprised, more
of it's just like stunned amazement
that God would let them be a part of this.
But that led Simeon to turn to them and prophesy this.
Look at verses 34 and 35.
Simeon blessed them
and said to Mary his mother, behold, this child is appointed
for the fall and rising of many in Israel
and for a sign that is opposed.
And a sword will pierce through your own soul also.
So that thoughts from many hearts may be revealed.
Now, what in the world did he mean by all that?
Well, first, he uses this language of fall and rising.
What that means is that with this Messiah,
there is no neutrality.
You are either for Christ or you're against Christ.
We either trip over him or are established by him.
What Simeon is saying here is
that this Christ is the fulcrum of history.
Everything hinges one way or the other on him.
But he also said, this baby would grow up
to be a sign that is opposed.
That sign is a strong word that means a manifestation
so visible, so clear that no one could miss it.
It's the same word used for the miracles
that Jesus would perform
throughout the rest of the New Testament.
The rest of the gospels that you see him do signs.
And what those signs would often do, remember the scenes
of him doing miracles?
There were people who were just like, thank you.
God is here kingdoms.
But then there were other people Who saw the same sign
and they said, no, he's not legit.
It would reveal their hearts, right?
He is the sign that would be opposed, even
for Mary herself.
She would have to decide that.
'cause Simeon here gave her a very personal prophecy
about her future, that she was going to stand there
and watch her son be crucified.
And as a parent, you would feel that, of course,
for her son being murdered, you'd feel
that deeply inside of you.
But, but it would be deeper than that even
where she would have to be confronted in that moment
of whether this is the saving son of God or not.
Even her heart would be revealed in this moment.
And so that's the scene we have here with Simeon
and Joseph and Mary and Jesus.
And, and, and listen, I get the blessing
of studying this all week,
and so I get to know it pretty well here.
But, but what I don't want
to have happen in my ministry life is
that these things like this, any text becomes academic.
It's just about what it says and getting it right
and making sure everybody's hurry, hearing what I want
to hear and what God wants to say.
Like it can't become merely academic.
So I heard another pastor do this and
and I did this this week.
I asked myself the question,
If Simeon is an example of faith in between,
so what would it look like to allow his words
and his life to, to kind of
diagnose me this week, to diagnose us?
Like what if we just hold his waiting life up against
our waiting lives and just see where we are?
So here I wanna ask three questions today.
Here are three questions for us to consider
as we allow the Lord to meet us in this as we allow him
to convict us and strengthen us,
and as we allow him to lead us to repentance as we need it.
Like, like, just, just ask a couple questions here
that I've been asking myself all week and,
and you'll hear wrestling with, but,
but just allow this to, to search you, search us.
Here's the first question.
Is the Holy Spirit upon us, like Simeon
is the Holy Spirit upon us?
Like Simeon's example showed he
was in Simeon's life.
Now, you, you read carefully when you read God's word
and Luke was clearly trying to communicate something to us.
Tell us something here,
because three times in three verses, God's spirit
is mentioned involving Simeon.
Now, did you see this? Verse 25,
the Holy Spirit was upon him.
Verse 26. It was revealed to him by the Holy Spirit
that he would not see death before he saw the Christ.
Verse 27, Simeon came in the spirit
into the temple.
So, so Simeon was clearly deeply connected
with God's spirit, and he was in tune with God's spirit
because he was so focused on God
and his work in the world.
How many of us would say
that we have a similar experience with God?
You know, if I'm honest, I would have to say that
that's not my experience.
Most of the time. You just look at the picture
of Simeon and how he was so in tune.
I I see so many differences
and many of us honestly would have the theological language
to say the right things about the Holy Spirit.
But do we really know him like Simeon did?
Are we being led
and controlled by the Lord where every thought,
every action is done in light of what he would want?
And listen, I don't want this to be, I don't mean for this
to be discouraging because we
need to remember something here.
We, we we're not in the same waiting game that Simeon
and those believers were in.
We're, we're a post, a big event.
And, and so, so we need to remember something here.
We as Christians have something
that those believers didn't have.
Here's how Ephesians chapter one puts
it in him.
In Christ, you also, when you heard the word of truth,
the gospel of your salvation
and believed in him, when you were saved, converted,
you were sealed with the promised Holy Spirit
who is the guarantee
of our inheritance till we acquire possession of it
to the praise of His glory.
See, the difference now, now that Christ has died,
resurrected and ascended, is
that he sent his Holy Spirit into believers permanently.
Simeon yes was one of a few,
but not every believer at that time
and all the way back in Israel had the Holy Spirit in them
like we now do Christian.
And what that means is what was true of Simeon
can be true of us.
The spirit was upon him. The spirit was leading him.
The Spirit is inside you believer.
And so what we have the opportunity to do is,
is we can have this, there's not some special formula.
Don't think you have to like, sell everything
and go move to the temple like Simeon or Anna.
Like don't think you have to go get in the woods
and just be in communion with God.
All that's not a special formula here.
All it takes is an open heart, open hands,
allowing him lordship of our lives
that he calls the shots, he directs, he moves and we follow.
By the way, just so you're hearing
what you're hearing right now, it's not an alarm.
It's not somebody's phone
after this service head, the lobby,
our special needs joyful sound choir is doing hand
bells of Christmas carols.
It is so good.
So as soon as we're done in here, head out there, right?
It, it's worth it. So just in case as you're hearing that,
that's what you're hearing over the next few minutes, but,
but just think about this is the Holy Spirit control.
Am I submitting like this?
Like what if, what if I allowed him to lead every step
of my life And, and just lived in that?
What if, what if I asked him,
God, what do you want me to do?
Who do you want me to talk to? Who do you want
me to sit by when I come in?
Like, what if we got out of our own way
in our lives and in here?
What if we got out of our own way
and just said, holy Spirit, you do whatever you want.
I think we would live more fully alive kind of lives.
It would look a lot more like Simeon.
I I pray God would do that in me.
So is the Holy Spirit upon us like Simeon, let
that diagnose you.
Here's the second question.
What is Christ revealing about our hearts?
Remember, that's what Simeon said to Mary at the end,
that this Christ, this child,
would be the fulcrum of history.
There's no neutrality when you consider Jesus.
You can't be halfway.
And so I asked that question of me this week,
and I had to be honest
and face the reality that
so often my heart is divided in its loyalties.
I mean, just think about Christ scanning an X-ray
of our day-to-day lives.
Where do our motivations land?
Like what's deep inside here?
Do we only give lip service to following Jesus?
I love the little nuance Simeon gave in verse 30 when he
prayed, my eyes have seen your salvation.
What was he talking about? That baby, right?
The baby. But,
but he, he hadn't seen Jesus do any of these things
that we know, know He came to do.
But Jesus is a baby. He's holding. I've seen your salvation.
God. This is what Spurgeon said.
Not only the worker of salvation,
but salvation itself.
That's who Christ is. Wherever we see Christ,
we see the salvation of God.
Not only that, he did things to bring salvation.
He's not merely the means to our salvation.
He's not merely the ticket into heaven.
That is not merely who Christ is.
No, we need to see Jesus as salvation itself.
Now, that means, of course, eternally his life, death
and resurrection purchased eternity for us, eternal life.
But also, remember John 10 10, he purchased life abundant
for you every day as well.
Salvation, not just when you die
or when Jesus comes back.
Salvation in everything you're facing right now.
Everything that would ever come your way,
everything you're ever tempted by, everything
that you ever long for.
He's your salvation.
But we have to see, we have to see him as Lord
to get there first, right?
So here, here's the third question.
What's Christ revealing about our hearts? Of course, yes.
But here's the, the final diagnostic.
Are we waiting like Simeon was waiting?
Are we waiting? Like Simeon was waiting?
Just think about what Simeon had experienced
at some point in his life.
The spirit of God told him explicitly that
before Simeon died, he would see Messiah,
all the hopes and dreams of thousands of years
of Israel's history.
He'd see it. So think about
how he would've lived in the, in-between
promise to fulfillment.
How would Simeon have, like, just think first.
How would he have gone into the temple?
Overjoyed, right? I mean,
you can almost see Simeon at this point.
He's walking in every time with his head on his swivel,
like he's expectant.
He's excited.
He's looking around
and he's wondering like,
is today the day I get to meet the Messiah?
Like the priest on duty that day?
Simeon, what are you doing, man?
Hey, I'm just checking to see if Messiah's
here, don't see him yet.
See you tomorrow. Like you, he would've,
he would've been different in his demeanor.
He'd been looking, looking, looking for some,
are we waiting for God like that?
And, and first I want you to think about, are we waiting
for God to move in our circumstances like that?
Are we expecting God to show off according
to his promises?
So I don't know what you're waiting on.
Maybe you're waiting on a relationship.
Maybe you're waiting on answers for an unexplained illness.
Maybe you're waiting for a job
or you're waiting for a prodigal child to come home
And listen, just as a side note,
when we're talking about waiting for something,
we're talking about a genuine promise from God,
a genuine move of God.
Not just like, I'm waiting on a million dollars.
Like no, we're not talking about that.
We're talking about genuine God, things
that he's promised or that he's going to do, right?
That's the idea we're talking about here.
And so whatever you're waiting for, wait,
like Simeon, wait, like Simeon be expectant.
Anticipate him like you're in a a really hard situation.
Okay? God, how are you gonna show off through this?
How are you gonna get more glory through this?
How are you going to prove yourself through this?
'cause here's the thing. We live in a culture
of instant gratification.
God doesn't work like that.
Psalm 27 14 says, wait for the Lord.
Be strong. Let your heart take courage.
Wait for the Lord.
That means humble submission.
God, you're gonna have to do this.
You're gonna have to move.
I'm waiting on you. And
so wait like Simmy in the circumstances you need
to wait on Absolutely.
But also this, and this is even more important for us.
Are we waiting for Christ's second coming?
Like Simeon was his first Simeon waiting
for Messiah to show up the first
advent, the first appearance.
We are after that one,
but we're still waiting on a second
advent for Christ to come back.
Are we waiting like th did for the Messiah?
Like I get so distracted by silly things in the world,
by these meaningless trivialities
that we prioritize in our lives.
And in so many days,
I don't even consider the Lord's return.
What if we all looked for
and worked for the kingdom of God
to come on earth as it is in heaven?
What if we kept our eyes on eternity?
I, I think we'd be way more earthly good
as we kept our eyes fixed on what's coming.
Righteous devouted, the values
of the kingdom coming through.
People who are focused on the kingdom
of God over anything here.
That's what we would look like.
'cause remember what an engaged couple is like.
They're excited. They're actively
preparing for the marriage.
Why are they so excited?
Because Their eyes are fixed on a date
to come in the future.
They wanna be ready. And even as they wait,
there's a thrilled feeling they have in their spirits
as they anticipate this glorious union of marriage to come.
Church. Listen, our wedding day is coming
where the lamb of God who takes away the sin
of the world will come back for his bride.
And so let's wait, church.
Let's wait in love watching, opening our lives
to the spirit's control.
Let's wait. Well,
I heard a story one time about how
these sailors on a Scottish fishing
boat we're returning home after many days at sea.
As they neared the shore,
they gazed eagerly toward the shore
and a group of their loved ones had gathered to greet them.
And the captain looked through his binoculars
and he began to identify some of the men's wives
that he could see.
I see Mary, there's Margaret, there's Anne.
One man though became concerned
because his wife was not there.
And later he left the boat with a heavy heart
and he hurried up the hill to his cottage.
As he opened the door, his wife came running up to meet him.
I've, I've been waiting for you.
He replied with a gentle rebuke.
Yes, but the other men's wives
were watching for them.
May we be a people actively waiting
and watching for the Lord to return.